the world seems like it's falling apart
at the seams where can we turn who has
the answers is it the politicians is it
humanism is it technology find out on
this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness
what's up everybody thank you for
joining us at led live we got a special
guest today his name is london and we're
going to be talking about the chaos in
the world today where is all this headed
if we choose one route like humanism or
if we put our trust in technology or
politicians where is this gonna take us
ultimately where can we turn for the
real truth and the answer to all these
problems in the world i'm looking
forward to hearing this presentation
because
you got a really nice presentation lined
up and i haven't seen it but it sounds
like you got some good research in here
yeah we we're excited you know the the
series is called the faith of jesus and
really we're focusing on finding the
answers to life's biggest question you
see there are so many problems going on
in the world and everybody claims to
have a solution right this person says
no if you want over here this that and
the other but as christians we have to
be able to go to the bible and say what
does the bible say and so what we're
looking at right now is man's problem
and god's solution let me say that again
man's problem and god's solution you see
when we look at the world what do we see
today we see we see a man-centered world
if you look back in history you look at
voltaire and you look at
all these philosophers and people have
desired that philosophy or academics or
all these things they promised that
these were going to be the answers to
man's problems they threw out the bible
in the french revolution they threw out
god out of schools and man has been
trying to build this utopian society
without god have we seen any any um
chain reaction from that well that's
what we're going to look at oh good and
so we look at humanism what is humanism
humanism is a system
based on man man's wisdom man's
philosophy man strength talent gifts
whatever you want to call it and so we
look at there's a philosophy that comes
as a result of this
humanism and so that now brings into
education academics now is based on man
and then you see an economic system that
is based on man then you have a
political system based on man and you
have industries based on man and now
we're living in what the technological
now we say that guess what technology
can solve all of our problems you see
you went through history and it was
philosophy was gonna then it was
economics then it was academia then it
was politics then it was industry the
industrial revolution but now we live in
this technological age it's kind of
interesting and also a shame that the
spotlight is put on man because you
think of a different scenario it's like
this giving accolades to the car instead
of the person who created the car
and like building society of what the
car can do and its capabilities instead
of talking to the person who made the
car and seeing what they have to say
about it
it's kind of backwards and so when we
look at the world
what has been the results what's the
fruit right you know we're all about the
fruit the world
celebrates execution they celebrate
people that are doing things and and
they're doing uh amazing things but what
is the
bible says you shall know them by their
fruits well i know that just in some of
my research
the bible was like part of a curriculum
part of the schooling prayer was part of
scribe and yeah there's a fine line with
this separation of church and state and
all that but once they got rid of that
they introduced a new theology evolution
is a theology right and so i don't think
you should
you know even if we can agree that yeah
maybe we shouldn't teach the bible in
school because it's a freedom of
religion thing
you shouldn't be introducing a new
type of theology where
we're all just an accident your life
doesn't mean anything you're an animal
you know well what we want to do is what
is the result of that philosophy what is
the result of that educational system
and so we look at the world we live in
today and it's full of violence right
violence is literally global
i just pulled some headlines you look at
at least 20 mass shootings have taken
place in two weeks since the uh metro
atlanta spa attacks
right so now is that just in atlanta
that's yeah that was in atlanta but
notice it started in atlanta and then it
went from atlanta then you had colorado
then you had virginia and so there's
this this this ripple effect there's
this copycat effect because people are
turning to violence right the bible says
about the days of noah it was because of
violence right every imagination and
thought was evil only continual leap
right and so there was also orange
california and so also we see the
results we see what full of stress
anxiety has gone through the roof
depression has gone through the roof we
look at fear right
that people are fearful of what's coming
for you rightfully so when you see
people getting killed just for going to
the stores right right and people are
fearful about this pandemic they're
fearful about uh all these different
things and the bible says that men's
heart would fail them for fear of the
things that are coming upon the planet
right and so we see not only just a
nation we see nations
that are fearful right governments that
are fearful and so it seems like the
world is literally spinning out of
control and so everyone sees what the
problem is and it's a cycle it doesn't
seem like humanity you know myself it
doesn't seem like i um get it because
all these elements
can be found all the way back
uh in in the garden of eden yeah with
the first family the result of i mean
the the effect which was the first
killing was a result of believing in the
lie that satan told that man
is the center man is better right man
should be elevated to that of god so
that goes back to the original lie
yeah that you
can have happiness you can have harmony
without
obedience without god
and so as we look at 2021 we see the
results of that garden of eden lie it
didn't work then it's not working and
and
trying to say that man is elevated to
god that's the whole evolution process
you know you are god right
if you're the god of your own world then
what's to stop you from killing somebody
that you're mad exactly
so it becomes increasingly evident that
human wisdom is not enough to solve the
problems facing humanity would you guys
agree with that yeah absolutely we've
seen it we've tried it and so notice
this quotation as nations are confused
and men's hearts are what failing them
for what fear and fear right you look at
the movies you guys specialize in movies
and look at the media look at look at
the morbidity
of of how people view themselves and how
they view their own world there's
fearful looking after those things that
are coming on the earth and so we look
at this collective fear right we look at
people are fearful if you don't have a
mask if you do have a mask do you have
this or you don't have that we just came
from a state close to here and we live
in a state where there are no uh
mandates for mass right and it was
literally like being in the twilight
zone we walked into whole foods and
literally everybody had a man and we
didn't have a mat and they looked at us
like what is wrong with you and we were
like uh do you guys have masks
and so it it it made us feel different
because everyone now you're the odd one
right right
and so
what about the social unrest right we're
looking at the the problem we're seeing
the results of this humanism right what
about uh thinking men they're looking
the politicians they're looking like how
do we fix this problem how do what's the
remedy for this problem what about labor
versus management have you guys been
driving down the street and seeing uh
looking we're looking for people to hire
bonuses fifteen hundred dollars right
right five hundred dollars at at uh
mcdonald's people people are not even
going to work anymore right so now
there's a labor management because guess
what labor has finally figured out that
hey you need us we don't need you
and so the power has shifted and so now
we see the protest lines now we see rent
they have the rent moratorium right and
so people are saying you know what i'm
not going to pay my rent and so now
people the owners are they can't even
legally evict their tenants i haven't
heard of this but
you know i i know with what's going on
i've heard that people say
i make more money now since i've lost my
job because of these buying checks or
whatever yeah it's like why go back why
what exactly why would you go to work
right so now the solution is how do we
get people back to work
right and so notice what about the
wealth inequality it seems like the rich
are getting richer and the poor getting
poor you think of those billionaires
they made hundreds of billions of
dollars during this time
whereas the the poor class are getting
poor and poor and the and the middle
class is being wiped out right so these
are the effects so we have the haves and
the have-nots right we have the the the
monopoly king you know the bezos of the
world and the average man like you and i
the average woman like us guess what
we're having to say how are we going to
feed our children how are we going to
put food on the table and so
will this nation fall into anarchy
because that's what they're saying have
you guys heard about the next thing
that's going to happen
is what
a revolution yeah people are tired of
this you have the right versus the left
and so all of these things are a direct
result as man trying to build this
system without god so the question we
come to is there a remedy i know you all
want to know okay we know the problem so
what is the remedy and so my question is
where has man looked for remedies so we
looked at what about educational system
you know when the pandemic kid i don't
know if you got were you guys ready for
the pandemic when it hit no
are you sure
i wasn't i was totally caught off guard
like the rest of the world right and so
now i have people because we've
homeschooled our kids
you know all the way through people
calling me like what do i do
you know the like because people are now
forced to deal with their own children
to educate them to work from home and so
guess what this is what what what home
looks like now upside down but guess
what this is proof the educational
system has proved a failure people are
not even sending their kids back to
school anymore they're saying i'd rather
have them home well what about uh
culture or civilization you know now
there's more isolation there's more
depression there's more problems mental
health is what right
it's running rampant because people are
gaming they're next netflixing and
chilling and and so now isolation and
then the pandemic you can't go out
for a month and a half
now we're up in a a year and a half and
so now literally the society is falling
apart right so what about law and order
they said hey we get law and order that
will be the remedy but guess what now we
see even two that has failed right now
they want to talk about defunding the
police then george floyd i can't breathe
and now there's racial tension explodes
and now there's a social crisis and man
is seeing the handwriting on the wall
right people are feeling that they can't
what sp you can't even say certain words
now right oh yeah if you say certain
words you might get pulled right right
they might red flag you and so you get
canceled so now council culture
is this is the new remedy well if you
don't say what what i believe and i got
the power i'm going to turn you off look
what they did to trump
yeah the president of the united states
if he can get cancelled
what about the little guy what about the
right and so now you have this racial
divide right so what about government
what do you guys think about government
can government give us the answer i
don't think they've ever been able to
have the answers
they're also having their own problems
with the debt
so now there's government shutdown now
there's political right and left and
pundits and now you have all these
things and so the political world is
literally in chaos right so this is the
result of humanism this is a result of
trying to build this system without god
so a world in christ is even without the
pandemics this is what they were saying
even before the pandemic the world was
in a crisis there was a financial price
there was a health crisis there was a
crisis in uh leadership so what about
the political leaders surely they have
the answers right
are you democrat republican independent
you know people are taking on these
ideas and philosophies and guess what i
believe they pulled the biggest hoax in
this last uh uh election
everybody they they pitted the right and
the left the black the white the rich
the poor and now we see i'm like where
are the politicians after the election
right i haven't seen the vice president
for like six months wow right so notice
the politicians so whether it be right
or left they have also failed what about
economics surely economics can save us
right
right can economics be the solution i
just got to get more money i got to get
more cash i got to get more capital but
guess what now there's a total uh
meltdown of our system there's a crisis
right
so that too is also failed so
have you
they stopped giving stimulus checks
right let's stop giving them i don't
know that yeah so
remember people when they first started
saying we're going to give you
this money people are like oh wow
they're so excited but guess what the
stimulus check what did people do with
it blew it they blew it on frivolity
right
so even when the solutions came to help
what are people doing oh wow so yeah
thinking of from a political mindset
they're like
you know maybe maybe the world just
needs a leg up you know we give you a
but start a business or something right
and instead they just parted it away now
wow
why did people waste
i thought that was actually the point
they knew what people would do so to
boost the economy they just gave the
money right because they know the
economy the money is going to go back
into the economy
because we have a wasteful
consumer culture really just proves that
the money has no value right we'll just
print it put it back in the system
so what about industry remember the
industrial revolution yeah right that
promise to take the world to another
level right but what's to been the
result
pollution look at this you go
environmental crisis so guess what
people are saying that there's a
environmental crisis where did that
start where did it come from before
america was a producing country when
america was great we produced and then
we switched to what a consumer culture
and guess what that idea and philosophy
has even come into the church we no
longer study our bibles we just come and
consume what the preacher has to say we
consume what this person has to say but
what happened to the
people that were the people of the book
right so we can see how these
philosophies have seeped their way into
our experience so we see the
deforestation we see the raging fires we
see the climate change so what about
technology sure you guys deal in the
technological space surely technology
can be the answer to humans problems yes
yes so so what has been the result
of technology um
man what did they call those couch
potatoes couch potatoes right i think um
also
an increase in as you mentioned mental
health because now it's like we rarely
meet face to face especially since the
pandemic we all got accustomed to zoo we
didn't like it but still we're still
behind social media and just
you know there's no physical contact or
quality time with people anymore right
that's to to the point where technology
is even creating
your spouse
now you you can have a robot woman
raising your children all right
or something yeah a little robot that
educates your kids
sit with your robot we're gonna go watch
a movie talking about human interaction
you know now technology's replacing jobs
so you can't even have a conversation at
the cashier right you just punch some
buttons have you been to walmart right
so you go the grocery store is now it's
nothing but what self checking self
checkout so they're removing the human
element or you can even go online and go
visit the big pipe
right the door opens and you get your
product right that was interesting
i went to one of those i was like this
is like the jetsons right i just walk up
to this big pipe and i get my product
out i must say this stuff is actually
really cool like i just want to play
that
it's really enjoyable but you know
checks and balances is like you know the
cause and effect the uh the the gains
and also the losses the sacrifices and
what's happening to society it's evident
that things are on the downfall it's
interesting i was a missionary my wife
and i were missionaries in japan so you
know japan is technologically advanced
like 20 years
yeah so so like carvana
that actually came from japan the the
car elevator that idea came so anyway we
were there and there and we watched the
tv commercial and had this guy and this
girl and they were walking and so they
pan they have him walking and then they
have her walking and they meet on the
corner and they're talking to each other
and you know what they do they turn
their backs to each other and continue
their conversation wow so what was this
this was 20 years ago was the commercial
it was a cell phone it was it was almost
making it glamorizing yes oh and so this
was 20 years ago
that we saw this commercial and now you
have a whole generation that they cannot
communicate wow have you noticed that if
someone's a gamer if someone's heavily
into media their social skills are
garbage non-existent can't take social
care right and so
it's awkward no eye contact
but guess what in the virtual world in
the technological world the matrix
right they can they can be whoever they
want to be yeah they can
project whatever they want to project
right it's good yeah that reminds me of
this other commercial that i saw i don't
know if it came from japan but um
it was this baby probably a few months
old crying and the mom kept trying to or
was it the dad they just kept trying to
put like you know ipad phone something
the baby just kept crying and then like
towards the end of the commercial
um the father or i believe the mother
whichever one the parents picked up the
baby and he stopped crying and it's like
wow
right it's the human connection that we
need it doesn't the baby does not need
right a screen to look at it needs
connection have you seen the commercial
where the with a child has an ipad i
mean has a newspaper and is doing this
to the newspaper trying to scroll so we
have a whole generation that has grown
up on nothing but technology right and
so this was supposed to be what the
answer to man's problems right and so
has technology failed 100 so we have
people who are you know media on the
mind right so now look at this picture
what what do you see here
it's all about perception perspective
you know and deception
on the screen it looks like what there's
an attacker going on right but in
reality
what's really happening he's actually
running for his life and that's the
devil he he's he's the god of this world
the bible says the bible says the god of
this world has blinded the minds of men
lest they see
the glorious gospel you can really
control
the mindset of masses when they think
when this is portrayed and they see this
oh this is what's going on i need to get
involved right whatever so i seen a
picture it was like from cnn or
something and it was showing on the tv
screen there's this guy and you see a
bunch of protesters behind him and then
somebody in the balcony took a picture
looking down it was literally like 10
people crowded behind him on the
sidewalk holding signs but the viewer is
like i need to get involved because i
need to take action on whatever i'm
talking about and you really just hired
10 people right
so
so we see this manipulative this
manipulation of the population right and
so here we see that violence but guess
what what about fake news now everything
is fake news right if it's not a part of
the big uh uh tech or the big uh
headlines
right if murdoch or or fox or anybody
doesn't say it then it's fake news right
and so here we see
fraud has gone up we've seen theft has
gone up right identity theft now people
are like
you can steal someone's whole identity
online or you can falsify an identity
online right so now we're dealing with a
generation that is what identity christ
people don't know who they are right
look look at our our young people they
have totally now it's them they he her
what's your pronouns like wait i get to
choose my pronouns now yeah you know
what what is your classification how do
you identify do you identify as black or
white or rich
right so this is like
that is so foreign to
all of human history
but now in this last moments of earth's
history we see this identity crisis i
have a question for you do you think the
church is suffering from an identity
crisis oh yeah oh it couldn't be what
are you talking about i think so
explain i think i think we've definitely
um
lost our ability to
i don't know we've traded the truth
really to make people comfortable that's
what i see
that's something that i notice is we
don't want to step on anyone's toes
anymore especially in cancel culture you
know everybody's offended
and it's like there's a larger emphasis
on loving people and i think it gets to
like a
almost a toxic point because it's skewed
because what does loving people mean it
doesn't mean leaving them in their sin
it doesn't mean
never um
you know speaking against something that
they're doing of course there's a way to
do it you always do things in love but
loving someone you don't
you don't allow someone to go down a
hurtful path just because you love them
yeah when you love your child that's
going towards the light socket with that
butter knife you'll say well i don't
want to hurt his feelings right right
just let him do it so i talked to a
young man yesterday i was at a a youth
gathering and he's in public school and
he got kicked out of his class
ciz for speaking about christianity and
he's very vocal and he says so why can
the muslims speak about muhammad why can
the buddhists speak about the bhagavad
gita why can every other faith religion
you talk about homosexuality you talk
about anything else but when i speak
about christ
now i'm hate speech even witchcraft
which and yoga meditation and all this
stuff you guys are talking about they're
teaching masturbation to kids
you know so so he's standing up for his
fate and he's being persecuted
for just talking to his peers in small
groups
and so
here we see uh the addiction culture has
gone through we see mental health we've
talked about stress and anxiety so what
do you think has technology provided the
solution that it promised or has
technology failed i wish we'd get an emf
and everybody just be without technology
for a little while i mean even though
it's like
it's what we do right it can be used for
good but it's been used for bad this
whole time that we just need a detox
right it's interesting you brought up
coddling like i just like to find
patterns and things and some things just
don't make sense when you look at it in
a different context uh talking about
coddling in the church because sometimes
we forget why people come to the church
to begin with right you know people
don't show up at a hospital and want to
be coddled no find the root of the
problem and fix it right so when someone
walks into the doors of the church
they're not looking for what's outside
of the church and looking for technology
and all these different things that
haven't worked they're looking for
something different a different kind of
a better a better truth right right a
real truth so so we see our hospitals
are overrun right so
every remedy that mankind has tried has
proved what
to fail a failure right now you don't
have to be a christian to agree with
that
you don't have to be a believer everyone
sees the handwriting on the wall but the
number one question is what is the
remedy then right and so it's amazing
that even though this humanistic
system has failed man refuses to look to
god yeah it's an abc culture anything
but christ anything but christianity
anything i mean
they accept the meditation and all that
right but they don't want to turn to god
so i have a question
are we happy with the results
what do you think is is is the society
happy with the results no no and i think
also there's a faith exercise but it's
not in god right now we're hoping for
things to get better in politics right
in economy exactly so we have faith it's
just a little bit misplaced and faith is
trust right so the bible says cursed is
the man that trusts in man and makes
flesh his arm
right so we are literally
bringing a curse on ourselves when we
trust in humanity
because humanity has failed from genesis
all the way till today right and so we
look at pollution so the question is
what is the remedy
okay okay what is the remedy
is it not time that the gospel of jesus
christ be given a chance will you i
think oh yeah you know we tried
everything else like when are we going
to turn
to jesus that's my personal testimony
in the beginning
churchianity didn't have the answers to
my tough questions because yeah that
we've lost sight of truth i had tough
questions they didn't know what to tell
me so i was like i'm going to look for
it everywhere else i looked everywhere
else
and came to this hopelessness emptiness
and finally my cousin was like just read
the bible man don't look to preachers
and right other christians hypocrites
and all that just read the bible and
give it a chance and i was like all
right i'll finally give it a chance
because i realized everything i knew
about christianity was from the pulpit
or from those who claim to represent him
when i went to the source come on change
my whole life man now jeremiah speaks of
uh how how israel had left the the the
living fountain and they went to broken
systems that can hold no
water and water is life right yeah you
can live without food for a couple days
you can live but water is life and so i
believe that christianity the
christianity of christ i want to clarify
that the christianity of jesus is the
only hope for humanity the last book of
the bible makes a statement that
perfectly represents the gospel and the
message needed for our generation so in
the book of revelation now what do you
guys know about the book of revelation
everybody knows that there's beasts and
there's this and that but you know what
the very first sentence of the book of
revelation says the revelation of
jesus christ
and the word revelation means to reveal
to unveil so the book of revelation is
about jesus christ and so in revelation
chapter 14 verse 12 it says here is the
what patience of the saints here are
they that
keep the comments of god and
the faith of jesus so i have a question
for you what's the difference between
having faith in jesus and having the
faith
of jesus wow
i guess faith in jesus is you you trust
him
you trust that he's there for you and
all that but the faith of jesus
wow jesus must've had a lot of faith
it's that in practice right
so many people believe in jesus yeah
right there you go but literally having
his very faith
right and this is the victory that
overcame the world even your faith but
guess what i'm fickle
i'm weak right so it's not my faith but
it's his faith and so here we want to
note two ideas number one
this group of people that the book of
revelation is identified they do what
they keep that word keep means to
protect when you have something valuable
what do you do with it leave it out in
the corner
no
protect it with your life right your
child you protect your your car whatever
it is you protect it so this group of
people they keep they protect they hold
it as value and what is it the
commandments of god and number two is
the faith of jesus so these two things
so i have a question for you when we
look at the commandments of god right
you know the ten commandments
where did these laws come from
god himself
god himself okay how do you know that
what's the evidence i i'm a teacher at
heart and so when you give me an answer
i want to ask you for some evidence it
says he wrote it with his own fingers oh
okay
okay so there's no translational error
between man and god it was right
okay so let's look at exodus 31 verse
18. uh uh mikey would you read this for
us and he god gave unto moses when he
had made an end of communing with him
upon mount sinai two tables of testimony
tables of stone written with the finger
of god
you just said that right so notice it
was two testimonies and it was what on
tables of stone why do you think he had
it on stone to show how permanent it is
permanency right the egyptians they did
the hieroglyphics why it wasn't for
themselves it was for their posterity to
be preserved right those messages that
philosophy the culture right so here god
is communicating and he says this is
permanent and matter of fact you said it
i'm gonna write it with my own finger
right so notice what exodus 32 verse 15
says uh kenny would you do that for us
please and moses turned and went down
from the mount and the two tables of the
testimony were in his hand
the tables were written on both their
sides
on the one side and on the other were
they written now it's interesting they
were written on two sides you know why
they were written on two sides
because back then that's how you had a
contract or a covenant oh wow so on one
side was one covenant and the other was
another and so it was on two sides right
and so here it says and the tables were
what
the work of god wait whose work was it
god's word it was the work of god
written and the writing was what
the writing of god right so i have a
question yes the ten commandments were
not on two stones they were just on one
stone front they were on two oh i see
right and so the work of god and the
writing of god so who gave the
commandments
god okay so it was his work and it was
his writing it wasn't moses it wasn't
anyone else right so
in a time of lawlessness that we're
living in now right when we look at
violence when we look at political
unrest when we look at global warming
and destruction
the bible speaks at a time when these
two principles need expression special
emphasis
and so
here verse 12 would you read
sure
here is the patience of the saints here
are they that keep the commandments of
god and the faith of jesus and so what
we want to do is we want to explore what
is the faith of jesus
if if christianity has the the remedy
right if the pulpit has the answer if
the word of god is exactly what it says
it is then why don't we see
the church
effectively
solving the problems of the world can we
make big claims right we're the remnant
church of bible prophecy we have this
and we have that but then we look at the
community
you know i'll end with this there was a
young a young man his name was nipsy
hustle you guys know who nipsy hustler
was he was a rapper and he was from
south central california that's where
i'm from
and and he was a philanthropist he was
an entrepreneur he used his uh uh
his platform to go back to his community
and he built a a community center he the
place where he used to sell crack he
went back and bought that whole uh strip
mall wow and he was setting up stem he
was setting up so much stuff he went
over and he was investing in bitcoin
early and he came back and he was
teaching people in the community in the
ghettos how to
get ahead how to get away from gangs and
he was working and he was murdered wow
he was murdered in cold blood
right there at his shop and he was
helping somebody
and guess what
all of los angeles
it was a bigger funeral than michael
jackson
and they mourned and they wept over this
man and a friend of mine
asked this question
if the local church
in that community shut down would they
have cared
[Music]
would they have
taken to the streets and said no you
have to open this church up it has been
such a what a blessing
so here is this man he didn't claim any
faith in god
here it is he was
but yet when he passed off the scene the
whole city mourned the pandemic hit all
the churches shut down
did the communities miss the churches
see these are tough questions these are
real problems that we have to deal with
and we have to find answers and so in
our next session we're going to look at
the challenge
wow man that's really powerful i was
thinking when he said
you're talking about nipsey nip c
hustles i think yeah
it reminds me of jesus you know
interacting with the community and stuff
and
and how he had such an impact on the
world
and
we have to have the faith of jesus so we
have to act as he did right and that
would make the community miss
the the people of the church if they
reflected the character of christ so
when you said
would society miss the church
probably not because they're not
reflecting the character of christ so we
have to understand what is the church
right is it the building or is it
exactly he says you are the body of
christ
he says you're a holy temple right but
in in our in our secularized christian
minds the church is now a building it's
for water
it's the pastor it's the bible worker
it's it's everyone else except for
me right but the book of revelation says
there's gonna become a group of people
that says hey not only do we keep the
commandments of god
not only do we protect it but guess what
we have the faith of jesus where did
jesus spend majority of his time
with the people in the highways in the
heavens with the prostitutes and the
pimps right right that's what jesus was
right his most extensive theology was
matthew chapter five through seven the
sermon on the mount the rest of jesus's
life was what he did
who he was right and the bible says in
revelation chapter 18 it says the whole
world is going to be enlightened with
his glory with his character of love of
patience kindness goodness merciful all
of that not in what we say talk is cheap
y'all come on right we don't need more
information we need more demonstration
right and so when people see a
transformed church a transformed person
like you
right
all your friends are like what
mikey became a what
right and that's why i believe this
channel is blessed is because it is real
it's dealing with real issues real
problems and coming with real solutions
absolutely and looking at jesus he was
able to be with those people because he
had something to give
right he's spent in time preparing and
just looking at the church what do we
have to give you and i mean wow we have
so much
right yeah james chapter 4 says faith
without works is dead it talks about
if you see somebody in need don't say oh
be blessed and be
be warmed and fed and walk away if you
don't
do something about it then
your faith without works is dead
so
let's give this last scripture it's
ephesians chapter four verse five and
six four and five and it says that
there's gonna be one body
there's gonna be one spirit there's
gonna be one hope there's gonna be one
lord one faith one baptism one god and
father and there's going to be one one
one church do we see that in the world
today no no no we see a splintered
fractured
dysfunctional body
and so what the book of revelation does
it spotlights and highlights this body
of believers who have finally become one
in jesus christ what's interesting is
the enemy
is basically going to make that happen
the counterfeit one church come on now
so we gotta be right we gotta be
studying the truth right so we can
identify what is the one true church or
the one
counterfeit church well revelation says
this one true church has two defining
characteristics keep the commandments of
god and what
faith faith of jesus
they have the remedy so now what we have
to do where is this church how do we
find this church i know you want to know
i i believe the bible gives us a clear
answer so you're not going to want to
miss our next session where we're going
to find
how to answer this challenge amen what a
cliffhanger thank you for that london
that's
really gives you a lot to think about
you know and i'm looking forward to the
next
the next one i hope you guys were
blessed by that if you were if you have
questions leave a comment in the in the
section below but where can they reach
you where can they find your ministry if
they want to talk to you personally so
uh we have a ministry our ministry is
called ten talents international
ten talent
t-e-n-talents dot o-r-g and we have more
information there and you can get in
contact with there or you can also email
me at london at t-e-n-talents.org
helping people to get that faith of
jesus awesome thank you guys for joining
us this week don't forget to like share
with your family and friends and that
simple thumbs up really helps get this
in the algorithm so don't forget to like
it and if you're new to this channel
don't forget to subscribe and we'll see
you guys next week
is there any hope for me
what can i do to unify my family on not
watching harmful media how do i know my
thoughts are my own and how can i
distinguish between impressions from god
i'm nervous when it comes to sharing my
testimony that is really that important
i stopped watching mainstream media now
what sometimes we get a lot of people
asking the same kind of questions so we
thought it would be cool to make these
little videos answering some of them in
a new series called i got a question
concise answers to your media related
questions
we'd love to hear from you reach out to
us privately on our instagram page or
facebook
and if you don't use social media that's
all right send us an email through our
website little light studios dot tv
slash contact us hey
we're here to help
we're here to help you
let your little light shine
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
welcome to the video bible study series
where we will explore a variety of bible
topics using video in print
what is humility do we need god's law
can i understand the holy spirit yes you
can and we're gonna solve that today in
five minutes or less they're designed to
engage you by watching a five minute
video having a discussion on the topic
and diving deeper into it with a lesson
study
each study asks questions has discussion
points and or has activities
overall we developed this project for
you to have a closer walk with jesus as
you explore relevant topics either in a
group setting or on your own we hope you
find these a blessing if you want more
information go to
www.littlelightstudios.tv
or find us on your favorite social media
platform
[Music]
you